good thing i forgot to put this shirt in
the laundry
because we have a lego star wars
holiday special trailer for
disney plus let's open this trailer that
they're going to celebrate
let's open this trailer they're going to
celebrate life day
star wars knowledge instant nerd cred
feeling good about the video
because the night before life day a
galaxy far
far away looking good tree food
decorations coming together heroes were
to celebrate the day please please
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i don't believe it you think maybe you
could put a shirt up for space and time
[Music]
oh this is cool oh
the child's you thinking what i'm
thinking
music dude everyone's in this
[Music]
you wanna shoot first after you
yo yo
that was so much better than i expected
it to be
i i don't care
if you don't like this this is so
this looks so fun this
is so cool i really loved it
i loved it that that that really
uplifted my mood
yes it's a holiday it's christmas in in
november
honestly i i didn't really have much
expectation going i thought it would
just be like a cute thing
i think legos and star wars there's a
part of that that kind of goes hand in
hand
i remember a movie fights episode on
screen junkies from forever ago
what franchise should get like a lego
adaptation
and someone was pitching star wars and
my first thought was well
i mean there's star star wars and legos
that's kind of always been a thing right
it's always
it's always been a thing so anything
lego in star wars naturally is like yeah
that that fits that's great but then to
do this
you know get this plot where rey gets a
key to
travel through time and space it opens a
door for a lot of
meta jokes a lot of self-awareness and a
lot of
crazy fan service crossovers that could
be done in
hilarious ways i mean i even saw briefly
you even see
young anakin skywalker and obi-wan
looking plucked straight out of clone
wars yeah they're like right in the
background at one shot so you're gonna
see them from all different ages the two
hans crossing over the different
father-son relationships i was honestly
really happy to see this yeah this this
looks like a total and this wouldn't
work in live action
it has to be happening it'll be lego
they've got mando and baby yoda in here
man they've got
them in here everyone's included and i
don't know if the
stormtroopers and the speeder bikes were
the same ones from the season finale of
season one amanda lauren it seemed like
their personalities were kind of riffing
on that as it stands and like this
this just looks wonderful
this looks really wonderful yeah what's
selling me on like you know because
there is a lot a lot a lot of just like
everything from star wars is in this
that you love and remember and you know
there is a certain level of the humor
especially from palpatine that could be
a little bit on the cheese end but i do
feel like that being said yeah like for
a holiday
special and for something that is as big
and expansive and heavily debated as
star wars and and for a christmas
special that's already a meme in reality
from before
times yeah this seems like the perfect
thing for the holidays it brings all of
our buds together it takes advantage of
the current wave of like
multiverse time travel hopping we'll get
every iteration of these characters and
yeah for a christmas
gift i feel like there are a lot of
places in which you can roll your eyes
at going oh we got everybody here and
we're gonna do all the nostalgia but for
this i think this is absolutely
appropriate
yeah and it seems like so much fun
because now i'm just like yeah i want to
see
as much as i don't love those like oh
we're gonna stop and break the fourth
wall to call something cute that we all
know is cute
kind of humor there are also other jokes
in here that i thought were actually
really sharp and funny like the whole
like it's a wrap
yeah just like the imagination started
to hook me and it started to make me
wonder like dang they really could go
anywhere in the star wars canon and that
seems fun
disrupt it because yeah it's like rey
shows up inside of luke's
x-wing and like you know it's wacky and
weird but at the same time
yeah let's get wacky and weird as long
as we're fooling around with the star
wars timeline and as long as we're going
back
like let's do it for fun light holiday
joy
instead of all consuming cannons
you know yeah man there's a part of it
that does feel like they're
taking inspiration and in terms of the
comedy style at least the
energy from the lego movie franchise
yeah which is fine little legos
and like the animations are different
obviously
but you know to have that kind of brand
it's kind of funny when you think about
it because the laura chris miller were
supposed to do a solo movie
and then it seems like they're taking
kind of their comedic
style uh maybe not their animation style
with their comedic
their energy and style they apply for a
lego movie and putting it over here
for lego star wars which i find kind of
ironic
you're gonna get more than just like the
big characters
uh you're going to get you know like the
little you see the wookies here they
mention
life day here yeah you got max rebo in
here
you have jokes about like kylo ren's abs
and
how like made fun of that word and last
jedi when they had that moment
everything that star wars fans or even
haters
have like made fun of star wars about it
sounds like they're going to acknowledge
it we've actually kind of i think
there's a big portion of the fan base
that hasn't been fully opposed to
time travel movie in the star wars
universe there's even a rumor going
around for a while that they
they might do that with rebooting the
last trilogy right some ridiculous rumor
yeah relegated to some obscure alternate
timeline
i mean like everything the star wars
canon the possibility of time travel is
it does exist they've done it before
but you know like this isn't about canon
this is just about taking about that
everybody
yeah just about having a plan with your
star wars
toys you know i don't really know how
you can hate on this one i kind of want
more people to watch this trailer
this this really did uplift my mood well
it makes me curious for the future of
disney pluses and all these streamers
original programming because to me at
the outset i was like oh this will
probably look like just like a cute
little special but it does look a little
bit more engaged like
it engaged me more than that i'm like i
actually kind of want to check this out
because it looks like a fun
lego star wars movie and maybe while it
might not be the kind you would go to in
a theater perhaps this will be a little
bit more than just some straight to
streamer
cash in special like it seems like it
could actually be pretty fun
legitimately and could be something i
want to put on every holiday i mean and
you do have a little moment here where
they are
celebrating christmas you know like
they're in the snow here
and i love like i love how they're going
through all the movies that's what's
great there is some this kind of wish
fulfillment about it
with rey getting to see luke skywalker
really
trained going to like the beginnings of
a new hope
the joke about darth vader my son i mean
the the two sons
yeah the binaries
yeah it was great and like that was a
great little piece of character comedy
and it was one of those ear marks of
this that made me wonder
maybe more uh uh work and care and
effort went into this than i originally
imagined you know like maybe this will
be something quite quite charming i'm
honestly
pretty impressed i'm surprised by how
i'm pretty surprised by this trailer
not gonna lie yeah it's like i feel like
they wouldn't have to try and yet they
really got me with it yeah
i'm hoping for for good stuff from this
yeah because there are
so many differences within the
personality especially with like older
luke and young luke and older han and
young han that you can totally make fun
of that and it looks like they're gonna
do that yes
yeah so happy i'm i'm not feigning
anything this is
real i'm so happy to look forward to
this christmas eve guys watch this
trailer again
share the share the trailer my god i
want more people to be excited for this
go play with your legos this is awesome
anyway guys please share the trailer
share a reaction if you want but more
importantly share the trailer
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell keep a lookout for our
reaction to the next episode of
mandalorian should be out this
weekend and last but not least let's do
a
i want to shout out today michael b from
omni media
i really want you guys to go check out
his channel
he does a lot of tv reactions but more
importantly the guy
really knows star wars uh if you watch
just uh
just alone his mandalorian season two
episode one reaction he picked up on so
many things
that we did not pick up on that many
other reactors didn't pick up
on he really knows his stuff and i
really think that if you want to watch
some mandalorian reactions
you're going to want to follow this guy
so please subscribe to omni media today
i guarantee you it'll be
well worth your time and he's just a
great guy he really is a great guy
overall i would share his channel
and everything even if he wasn't part of
the patreon page if you guys follow us
on the community page
you'll see that i often share other
people's videos and channels and he
would definitely be one of them
so michael b thank you so much for being
here bud i hope you're
doing all right right now hope you'll
talk to you soon bud you're the best
that's what the b stands for
you got it got it in there got it got it
i slipped it it's like oh i'll do all
greg talks for a minute what would
the beast
[Music]